you know there is a degree yeah called
um poultry science no way jack off
chickens what do you mean jack off
chicken I mean jack off a chicken what
do you mean you just like there's more
science than that to poultry yeah sure
but that is one of the things you learn
yeah that's what you gotta know okay
like that's one of the classes yeah
jacking off horses chickens whatever and
people I'm not kidding graduate 250 000
a year there is so much no one wants to
do that exactly fighting tooth and
that's their job no chickens actually
have huge [__] yeah could we get the
picture of this nice nice very much
appreciate that yeah so much money my
wife would be great at that job
I'll go give me that one